-Our next guest is a very funny
actor and comedian
you know from his work
on "Saturday Night Live,"
"Mr. Mayor," and
"The Secret Life of Pets."
His children's book
"Not All Sheep Are Boring!"
is available now.
Please welcome back to the show
our good friend Bobby Moynihan,
everyone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the club
of celebrity book authors.
[ Laughter ]
-We did it!
-We did it.
-We deserve it.
Now, I've written
one of these, as well, Bobby.
-Yes, I read it.
-Thank you.
-Thanks.
-You found the time?
-I did. I did. Long one.
It was a long one.
-It was a long one.
I actually have had parents be
like, "It was a little long."
But this --
The question that I gotta ask --
what was your inspiration for
"Not All Sheep Are Boring!"?
And how long did it take you,
the process, to write this book?
-The inspiration --
I have a daughter now.
Doing a lot of bedtime reading.
And the topic of counting sheep
to fall asleep came up.
And I thought, "Why is that?"
It's 'cause they're boring.
It's 'cause they're --
-Yeah.
-They're a very boring animal.
And that's why people do it.
So I sat in my bathroom
for an hour and I wrote a book.
[ Laughter ]
-So it only took an hour?
-Maybe a little less
than an hour. No, no, no.
No, I thought about it
for a very long time.
-Oh, yeah.
You put hours and hours.
-Hours of toiling
and then in the bathroom...
FDADADADADA! Real quick.
-Do you do your best writing
in the bathroom?
-I only write in the bathroom.
Pandemic. I lived in
the bathroom for two years
pretty much during the pandemic.
-There's a -- There's a toad
character, which is a --
Your daughter -- One of your
daughter's favorite animals.
-Yeah, look at him.
He's a little toad guy.
-Yeah.
-Such a little cutie.
-How did Dorothy --
-Julie Rowan-Zoch
did the art for this.
She -- She's absolutely amazing.
Dorothy --
Yeah, I like little fat toads.
-Uh-huh.
-I thought it was going to be
a big fat toad, but he turned
out to be a little guy,
and I'm fine with it.
-You know what?
I heard -- I heard -- So, this
is the beautiful artwork there.
-Yeah.
-But you -- you tried.
You gave an early effort
to do the art yourself.
-I -- Yeah.
I used to draw when I was a kid.
And I was like,
"I can draw this book, too!"
And I was wrong. I was wrong.
-Yeah.
-I tried.
-But you didn't do a terrible
job. These are way better --
When I heard you were
going to do the drawings...
-That's where everyone goes.
Like, I remember telling them,
"I want to draw the book."
And they went, "Oh, great!"
-Well, this isn't bad.
That's a sheep
with a secret, right?
-I think he's a little --
[ Laughter ]
He's evil.
-Yeah, he's really evil.
-Yeah, yeah.
Maybe he was
terrifying children.
-But these aren't --
These are good.
-These are the picture--
[ Laughs ]
Yeah, I sent them these,
and they were like,
"We're going to send you
a couple illustrators."
And I'm extremely glad I did.
But I tried.
-Yeah. I think you did.
Is Dorothy -- Does she like it?
-Yeah, she loves it.
She loves reading in general.
She likes me, which is nice.
-That's nice.
-And I wrote it. Yeah, no.
She -- she really likes it.
She likes "Pierre."
She likes -- She likes anything,
like, spooky or weird.
-Do you -- Having done a lot
of voices for animated things,
does she like when
you do voices when you read?
-Uh, sometimes.
We do -- Like, the hour before
bed is just an improv show...
-Yeah.
-...in our house.
But every once in a while now,
she's getting to the age
where I'm like, "Dorothy!"
And she goes, "Please stop."
Immediately.
Immediately, "Please stop."
-[ Laughs ]
My kids hate when I do voices.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah, they just want me
to read the words.
-She has a -- a Mel
from "Secret Life of Pets"
that, like, when you squeeze it,
it's my voice.
And she'll go -- pff --
and just smack it.
Yeah. [ Laughs ]
She's not a fan of that one.
-She is not --
Does that mean
this improv-show thing --
does that mean she does not
go to bed right away?
-No. The hour
before sleep is -- is both --
is my wife telling both of us
to calm down.
-Oh, I see. Yeah.
-Yeah.
I -- I put her to bed sometimes,
and she goes to bed
45 minutes later
because I'm just
being a weirdo with her,
and I think it's fun.
-Yeah.
They're good when they're --
When they're a good audience,
it's really fun.
-Yeah, it is.
She's a good laugher.
Yeah, she has
a lot of characters.
-Oh, she does characters, too?
-Yes, very much so.
Crazy shopper
is a big Dorothy character.
-Really?
What does crazy shopper do?
-Okay, all you have to do --
If you will be me
in this situation.
-Okay.
-Just say, "Well,
time to open my store."
-Okay.
"Well, time to open my store."
-[ Screaming ]
And then she just runs in
and knocks everything down.
That's crazy shopper.
-Crazy shopper.
-I didn't -- I didn't
want to ruin your desk.
-Thank you very much.
-You're welcome.
-That's a good character.
-Uh, crazy shopper.
Mr. Mustache.
-What does Mr. Mustache do?
-He's got a mustache.
-Great.
-Yeah, he talks --
and he loves talking about it.
-Loves talking
about the mustache.
-Yeah. Baby unicorn
has to be carried everywhere.
-Mm-hmm.
-Baby unicorn's legs
are not very strong.
-Yep.
-And then Evil Dorothy.
-Evil. Wow. She has --
She's already learned
that you can have
an evil version of yourself.
-Yes. Evil Dorothy.
Where's my camera?
This is Evil Dorothy,
is just this.
She just goes...
[ Laughter ]
-And we should note --
she's 19, right?
-She's 19 years old, yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey --
-She's a writer on your show!
-Yeah, she's a writer.
She's great. We love you.
Well, we love Dorothy.
We don't love Evil Dorothy.
Speaking of characters, you did
one of my all-time favorites,
Anthony Crispino, right here.
-Oh, look at these children.
-Yeah, look at these children.
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I feel like even --
even the colors of our clothes
have gone gray.
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, life has just gotten --
-Yeah, everything
is a little more muted.
-Life has just gotten gloomier.
Look at that background.
-Alright.
So, Secondhand News,
Anthony Crispino --
he was famously -- I mean,
it was a character
you and Colin Jost wrote.
-Yeah, yeah.
-But it was about a guy who
sort of got the news secondhand
and maybe got
some of the details wrong.
-Yeah, was always afraid
of people hearing it, too.
-Yeah, he had
top-secret information.
He was fine to say it
on "Weekend Update,"
which is national television.
-Fine to say it
on national television, yeah.
-Could we do a few?
Could I feed you a few
and see what you think
Crispino might say about it?
-Sure. Let's do it.
It's been a while.
-Okay. So here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, you know, I think the way
we would do this -- Yeah, yeah.
Hey, Anthony, I don't know
if you heard about these
Mar-a-lago documents. They...
-Oh, yeah. You hear
about this thing, though?
Oh, it's so good to see you.
-It is good.
I really like that we're --
This is a real flashback.
-It really feels
very calm, very normal.
You hear about this thing,
though?
-What's that, Anthony?
-Marge Simpson
found some documents.
Turns out she's dating
Master Splinter
from the Ninja Turtles.
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles.
You heard it here first.
-It's not -- it's not Marge
Simpson's. It's Mar-a-lago.
-Eh...pretty sure
it's Marge Simpson, though.
Pretty sure it's Marge Simpson
dating Splinter
from the Ninja Turtles.
-No. It's "special master."
-Highly topical!
-It was --
It was rumored...
[ Laughter ]
It was rumored Harry Styles
spit on Chris Pine.
-Ohh, boy.
You hear about this?
Even more topical,
Harry Hamlin...
[ Laughter ]
-Harry Hamlin?
-Yeah, Harry Hamlin.
You know the guy
with the nice hair?
-Yeah, from "L.A. Law."
-Yeah.
Of course, from "L.A. Law."
-Where you think he's from?
"St. Elsewhere"?
He split a tree in half
with his head. Pine tree.
-No.
Harry Styles spit on Chris Pine.
-Eh, pretty sure it was
the other way around, Seth!
I can't even get
that high anymore. I'm so old.
-Yeah, that part
of your voice is gone.
Yeah, thank you for stopping by,
Anthony Crispino.
It was great to see you.
-Thank you for having me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're also...
-That was -- That was
truly fun and cathartic.
Thank you for that.
-It was great to do.
I mean, we -- it was a --
it was always a very fun time
with you out there.
You were -- you were --
-The best. That was my --
My most favorite moments
were with you on "Update."
-Yeah, Anthony Crispino
would get very high in a way
that I feel like only dogs
could hear him at some point.
-Yeah, that was the point.
I believe we did
that joke once where --
I think you're right.
Dogs started barking. Yep.
-Where dogs started barking.
-You're doing the
"Batman: Audio Adventures."
You're doing another season
of that.
That's our friend, Dennis
McNicholas, who wrote those.
-Yeah, the best. He let me
play the Penguin, my dream.
-Yeah.
-It's so much fun.
-And then you're also --
You just finished
wrapping a film where
Jerry Seinfeld directed.
-Yeah, yeah. It's called
"Unfrosted" for Netflix.
All about the story of
how the Pop-Tart was made.
Extremely true story.
[ Laughter ]
-Like documentary quality.
-Documentary --
Getting to the hard stuff
about the Pop-Tart.
Yeah, yeah.
-That's very exciting.
I mean, I find it to be a trip
just to talk to Jerry Seinfeld.
It must be amazing to be
directed by Jerry Seinfeld.
-It is. It's very strange.
Just hearing his voice
in general go like --
It's Jerry Seinfeld.
-Yeah.
-And you feel like
someone's doing a bit.
I feel like
Jay Pharoah is around.
-Yeah.
-Because -- Because it's just
somebody doing his voice,
but then he's looking at you
talking and saying your name,
and you're going,
"Okay, Jerry Seinfeld."
Like, it's hard
to get past that.
-Yeah, well, I'm very excited
to see this,
and I'm always excited
to have you here.
Congratulations one more time
on the book, everybody.
It's called "I'm Not Scared,
You're Scared!"
-Wait a minute!
-Alright. Hold on.
"Not All Sheep Are Boring!"
I'm sorry. It's on sale now.
We'll be back
with more "Late Night."
-Thank you, buddy.